one of the reasons progressives say they
hate donald trump is because he
lies a lot trump they'll tell you is a
committed liar
an inveterate one to prove the point the
left has set about trying to
catalog trump's dishonesty with the kind
of scientific precision you normally
associate with
obsessed baseball fans or amateur bird
watchers
as of last month according to the
washington post donald trump has made a
total
of 13 435
false or misleading statements while in
office
as the post points out the line began at
the inauguration
perhaps you remember this claim which at
the time deeply offended official
washington
here's a picture of the crowd
now the audience was the biggest ever
but this crowd was
massive look how far back it goes we're
not going to lie to you
that was untrue the crowd at the 2017
inauguration was not the largest
ever measured on the national mall sorry
it wasn't
why did the president claim it was well
because that's who he is
donald trump is a salesman he's a talker
a boaster
a booster a compulsive self-promoter at
times he's a full-blown bs artist
if trump hadn't gotten rich in real
estate he could have made a fortune
selling cars
most people know this it's obvious
transparent really
so is lying really the reason the left
despises donald trump or
could the problem be as is so often the
case the exact
opposite of what they claim it is think
back over the last four years
when have the cnn anchors been the
angriest was it when donald trump told
some whopper
or exaggerated his own accomplishments
no
they're used to that kind of lying
everyone who spends time around
politicians is used to it
what infuriates official washington is
not when trump lies
it's when he tells the truth truth is
the real threat to their power
there's an unspoken agreement among the
people in charge of our country not to
talk about what has happened to it
they are personally implicated in its
decline for one thing
often they're profiting from it the last
thing they want is a national
conversation about what went wrong
and so they maintain an increasingly
strict policy of
mandatory reality avoidance everything's
fine they shout
voices rising in hysteria diversity is
our strength shut up or we'll hurt you
but trump won't shut up he keeps talking
that's his crime
that's why they hate him it started with
his very first speech as a presidential
candidate
when mexico sends its people they're not
sending their best
they're not sending you they're not
sending you
they're sending people that have lots of
problems
and they're bringing those problems with
us
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime
they're rapists and some i assume are
good people
now trump didn't claim that everyone
coming over the southern border is a
criminal
but some are and that's true and
precisely because it is true
you are absolutely under no
circumstances allowed to say it
acknowledging that not every illegal
alien improves america
raises an uncomfortable question if
illegal immigration has a downside
then why has washington allowed so much
of it
if the people in charge actually cared
about us they would protect our borders
but they don't care so they've let
millions and millions of foreigners
whose names we don't even know for
certain stream in from abroad to use our
services
lower our wages and yes in some cases
commit crimes
that's all true which almost by
definition made it unacceptable to say
the news anchors pretended that by
saying it trump was somehow attacking
defenseless mexicans
but actually he was attacking them the
gatekeepers in our national media
the people who should have been sounding
the alarm about all of this but instead
made common cause with the ruling class
they were supposed to be covering
and keeping honest our system is rotten
and corrupt and the news media are a
major reason for why that is
that's what donald trump pointed out and
not surprisingly
they despised him for doing it ask
yourself
what's a bigger scandal to your average
journalist the fact that homicidal ms-13
gang members have flooded into this
country from central america
and now terrorized communities from los
angeles to long island
or the possibility that someone might
complain about that
well we don't need to guess the answer
because last year donald trump
dared to complain about ms-13 watch
so when the ms-13 comes in when the
other gang members come into our country
i refer to them as animals
and guess what i always will
now keep in mind that the motto of ms-13
is literally
kill rape control
you might not have known that since
details about what ms-13
actually is and what ms-13 actually does
have received
far less media attention than donald
trump's criticism
of the gang murdering with people with
knives might be bad
but insulting illegal alien murderers is
in the moral hierarchy of washington
a far greater sin there's a serious
problem with the president dehumanizing
any group
of people in the united states even if
they are hardened criminals
the history of political leaders
dehumanizing opponents
even criminals and using animal
metaphors is a dangerous one and it is a
very slippery slope when you start
dehumanizing
people this way it's what the nazis did
we're all god's children
when the president of the united states
says about undocumented immigrants
these aren't people these are animals
you have to wonder does he not believe
in the spark of divinity we're all god's
children she tells us
spoken like someone who knows her own
children will never face the
consequences of the policies
she supports lost in the haze of all
this moralizing was any meaningful
discussion of those policies
now a cynic might say that was by design
it was the whole point of the tantrum
it's certainly a theme in washington a
similar passion play unfolded just a few
months before when the president was
heard speaking candidly about
immigration in the white house
during a conversation with advisers
trump asked why so many immigrants
come to the u.s from impoverished
countries if immigration is supposed to
make america better he asked
shouldn't we try to draw people from the
most advanced societies
well it's an obvious question you could
debate it of course but it's a real
question
so of course cnn had to scream at you
just to make sure you would never ask
that question
this is a very deeply offensive uh
language it says
the president quoted here why are we
having all these people from
whole countries come here president
trump's shocking and racist remarks
about immigrants coming from
whole countries sparking discuss tonight
do you have an example of any
whole country that the president
referred to that is predominantly
caucasian
i'm not surprised and in one way i'm
proud i am a proud
polar no we are not all created equal
at least not if you are born in as the
president put it a
whole country my desperate grandparents
from a country
that was considered by people like the
president
oh the posturing but let's be real is
there a single living person who
disagrees with trump's assessment of
haiti
probably not certainly haitian
immigrants agree with him that's why
they moved here
nobody on any of the cnn panels you just
saw is relocating to haiti anytime soon
for
the same reason oslo helsinki vienna
vancouver no problem
port-au-prince no thanks so if you want
to know what people
actually think ignore what they say
especially on television watch what they
do
no one really believes haiti is an
appealing place on the other hand
criticizing haiti in public calls into
questions decades of
elite approved immigration policy so it
must be forbidden
lest our leaders be embarrassed that's
what it's about that's what it's
always about pick a topic
last year after the killing of saudi
columnist jamal khashoggi
president trump said in effect that
while he disapproved of the murder of
course
saudi arabia remains a u.s ally the
president
cited the 450 billion dollars worth of
saudi investments in the united states
as well as saudi agreements to buy more
than 100 billion dollars
in american military equipment if we
broke our alliance with the saudis he
said
the us economy would suffer and china
and russia would benefit instead
now whatever you think of the saudis and
most sober people find them revolting we
certainly do
what he said is literally true this is
the arrangement we have this arrangement
we have had with the saudi kingdom for
generations now
everyone in washington knows that
because a lot of them are actually on
the saudi payroll
trump's crime was saying it out loud
that's always the crime
and the same of course is true with
baltimore baltimore may be the most
depressing big city on the eastern
seaboard ever been there
everyone in washington's been there it's
only an hour away
if you want to take the acela from
washington to new york
you have to pass through baltimore and
if it's daylight out there's no denying
the awful reality of the place
this summer the president told the rest
of the world what it's like
baltimore he said is a quote rodent
infested hellhole
not to mention a corrupt mess all
undeniably true
the latest mayor of the town just went
to jail again
but the obvious follow-up is why is
baltimore so bad
how did it get so poor and so hopeless
and of course part of the answer is
50 years of uninterrupted democratic
party rule hasn't helped baltimore very
much
but saying that would be embarrassing to
the democratic party so the party's
apologists don't want to have that
conversation
instead they attacked the man who tried
to start it
this weekend racist messages raging from
the president's twitter feed
donald trump masterfully makes it a
racist debate about baltimore
another racist attack on an
african-american member of congress and
the city he represents
well the president is as he usually is
or often is disgusting
and racist he uses a racist appeal he
uses a bait and switch
in the most bigoted and racist way
meanwhile in washington the leaders of
the episcopal church and for the sake of
technical accuracy
imagine air quotes around the word
church issued a florence florid
statement calling the president's words
about baltimore quote
dangerous they no doubt felt virtuous
issuing that statement but nothing in
the end changed in baltimore
baltimore remained actually dangerous
not in some theoretical academic
episcopal church kind of way
where all the violence is to your
feelings but real danger the kind where
your kid gets shot riding his bike to
the store
that's what life is like in the physical
city of baltimore a place where
msnbc contributors and left-wing
protestant clerics fear to tread
that place is still sad and desperate
and screwed up and absolutely not
one person in washington dc cares at all
that it is except the extent that they
want to make certain that you never
think or talk about baltimore
because thinking or talking about
baltimore or for that matter thinking
you're talking about i don't know
mass immigration the war in afghanistan
middle class life expectancy and decline
pick something thinking or talking about
any of that might point up
their own egregious failures and
selfishness
which are profound and whatever we do we
can't bring that up
because it's embarrassing so instead
let's just agree that donald trump is a
racist liar and move on and by the way
did you know that he's up to almost 14
000 lies by now my gosh what a bad
person he is
unlike us